what do you got for me tonight buddy
well uh i like your list
and your the quadrants that you made i
would suggest um
okay so the unplugged beta
the archetype
would generally be
black pill doom pill people right
there are some guys that go into that
category absolutely yeah
well
i would say
well i refer to like what rollo said
right where not every man can be
alpha and so like the beta
is probably going to be the alpha's best
because for every alpha he's going to
have good friends who are also beta
and when you have
so many people
that have that trump
and are
you know looking for
they're looking for
some type of community to go to and so
sometimes they plug into that
doom pill
community they could they could do that
well what would be a good way to tap
into that community to kind of transform
them
in a way to actually help
did you did you catch the show from the
start or did you jump in kind of halfway
through yeah i watched from the
beginning yeah okay so so the um
unplugged beta guys
um you know when you're talking about
assisting with their transformation a
lot of them don't want to deal with the
solution they just want to be mad
okay and there's nothing that you or i
or anybody can do about that if if
that's your choice and that's where they
want to be cool
you know you can commiserate you can
sulk and wallow you know you can be
upset everybody else because just being
yourself was not good enough you know
women society
uh making serious bank requires some
serious work some serious changes
um like i said again when i kicked it
off it's very very unlikely that you're
ever going to move
most of these people into a category
where they
you know get to the self act
actualization what was it it was
maslow's hierarchy of knees did you
do you remember that from school
yeah you know at the very bottom it's
like the basic needs in the very top
it's like the self-actualization that's
what the unplugged alpha is okay
the the unplugged beta guys
they just aren't willing to do the work
you know a lot of these guys are like
well if
guys like brad pitt couldn't do it and
you know keep a girl down you know what
chance do you have
you know like and then they kind of like
make up reasons why they they don't want
to move to that air which is fine you
know stay there you know you see the
code in the matrix you see the truth
but if you're gonna stay around and get
mad that's not your responsibility my
responsibility anybody else to assist
them in their transformation
transformation comes from within
you have to actually like make a
decision yourself to update your beliefs
and say okay
this is where i want to go in life
these are the choices that i need to
make to go there in life and then start
doing the work every day
well what would you
what would you advise a person who
does
deal with that anger
you know because that that's kind of
where are you mad right now like are you
still pissed off
i mean i'm
not i mean i think that is more of an
existential
anger if you know
so
for you are you making six figures yet
no but i mean i'm on my path
sorry so
you're on your path
oh yeah okay but the tren but that
transformation it takes time right it's
yeah there's no there's no like fingers
that i can click to make this like
happen overnight right like this is a
slow progressive
movement of you making better choices
every day every week every month every
year they're going to get you to where
you want to be i mean i'm close to 50.
i didn't get there when i was 20 or 30.
right like it took me a long time to get
to where i'm at and i didn't fully
unplug from society's lives until i was
like 39 40 dude
right but i figured out the money part
early on right like i figured out how to
make bank in my like 30 31 years old
like that's that's when i started you
know to hit like the full stride so
don't be mad be better is basically what
it boils down to
like get into the gym lift weights
improve your physique uh figure out you
know what you're calling in life might
be start doing stuff go out experience
things travel you know put yourself in
in different rooms take up new hobbies
that that might give you experience and
exposure to better people um but
taking
daily steps towards excellence is
it's not like a pop a pill and rubber
cream under your eye and lose you know
20 years of wrinkles and you know 20
pounds in three days by popping that
that pill it's it's slow progressive
changes every single day in your life
and and and sitting around being mad is
a wrong place to be like what do you
like what do you spend your time doing
when you're not leveling up like you
watch youtube videos or you're on social
platforms you're on reddit you play
video games like what do you do
uh
well you know i'm always reading i mean
philosophy robert greene um
you know i'm not a block right now i'm
on a philosophy binge
but just in general i mean for someone
like me i'm speaking me personally
because i kind of identified
with
a little bit with each of the archetypes
right yeah like i said earlier you know
you could take like an oval circle and
kind of blend over like two or three or
maybe even four of them
yeah and you know i think that you're
you're more on the top category
okay but you're more in the beta side
than you are on the alpha side because i
can tell that you're not you're not
getting all the results you want you're
still more in the pissed offside so
maybe there's some overlap there you
know somewhere between the unplugged
alpha and the unplugged beta but you're
more on the unplugged beta side
yeah well i mean that's okay right
because every like 80
of people are
likely gonna
be beta
well i mean the point being is recognize
where you're standing what the starting
point is because that's a
then then paint a picture paint a vision
of what b looks like and then every day
do things that get you closer to b if
you're if you're doing things that don't
get you closer to that vision to that
you know to that accomplishment of b
stop doing them
right
i mean like you've got to be willing
it's right here i mean david just
put the words in my mouth you have to be
willing to do what the others aren't
willing to do
and it's dressed in overalls and it
looks like work and it's going to be
hard
and it's going to be different and it's
going to be uncomfortable
but it's but it's going to be worth it
if you want it bad enough
well
does that make sense
oh yeah i i think that a lot of people
especially in the black pill i i really
do i pity them and i feel bad for them
because do you do you consume black pill
content because i've heard you mention
that term if you i mean
i i really don't even know what
black pill content is
just okay so let me put it to you this
way so what do you spend time watching
when you're watching youtube like what
youtube channels you watch
um
usually
well you're calling it red pill but
maybe it's not so what do you watch
i mean
rich cooper trey francis i mean uh just
like the news
you know news
news clips you know tucker carlson
or just history a lot of history okay
but like why do you watch news
well that's a really good question
um
because news is mainstream media and if
you go back to the quadrants on that
screen
people that are plugged in
watch mainstream media and news do you
have cable
no where do you watch news
um
just youtube clips
yeah so don't don't like you know i
unsubscribe from those channels
it's like
it's like walking down the sidewalk and
you see a piece of dog there and
then stepping in the dog and then
getting mad because you stepped in the
dog instead of walking around it
like that's what the news is basically
going to serve you it's going to serve
you dog it's it's designed to
create outrage are you on my email list
turtle
no i'm not
you should get on my email list because
i just added a documentary to it which
you're not going to see anywhere else
and i can't talk about publicly here
let me put the banner up again so you
guys have it
get on my email list that's the that's
the url i think it's like the eighth
email on my list all of the emails have
something important they're spaced out a
day or two just get on the list and
watch that documentary that i send out
and it breaks down exactly what their
what they're feeding you why they feed
it to you it's very very clear
i i shared the video my community over
the weekend and there was a lot of top
shelf like i'm talking like
multi-millionaires that watch it they're
like this this is very accurate this is
the most accurate thing i've ever seen
well i'll check it out um
i would just like that to add that like
a lot of the when i i mean stuff on
youtube i'm only half watching like in
the background kind of like white noise
right but the main thing that
that i have done which has provided a
buffer from going down the doom bill
is that
i do work out i do read books i you know
am journaling and working on myself okay
you know
and so
i
i'm saying to look at these quadrants as
like a market is like uh
you know different sectors of the market
you know there has to be a way
to kind of help
the despair among
men
why why are you trying to save everybody
else when your life is screwed up
well i wouldn't say my life is screwed
up well you don't want to well you're
not at where you want to be and one of
the reasons why you're not at where you
want to be is because you're trying to
fix the world before you fix yourself
i would say
that i want to provide what i can
you're not in a position to bring
anybody anywhere because you can only
bring people as far as you've come
that's like one of the things that
drives me nuts about you know a lot of
people that broadcast stuff on social
media and youtube is they purport to be
something but they've only done work for
a few years
and you can only bring somebody to where
you've gotten to and if you haven't
achieved the pinnacle of success you're
not in a position to be talking about
anything you really shouldn't listen to
people that are talking about that stuff
to me whenever i see these guys that are
younger it's like
you are not in a position to offer any
advice to anybody you haven't lived
anything you haven't seen anything
right
you've done nothing with your life so
when you're seeking advice
ask yourself would i trade lives with
this person you know has this person
done anything of any significance right
one of the things that you'll see a lot
of these guys that like to sulk and
commiserate they're like oh well uh i
don't know what they say about me oh
like oh rich uh got divorced so what
does he know about women or what does he
know about marriage or what does he know
about like this or the other thing it's
like
the very fact that i went through the
entire process from beginning to end
qualifies me to talk about the process
you know the fact that i've talked to
over a thousand men now one-on-one
qualifies me to talk about the process i
don't need a piece of paper on the wall
framed in mahogany with little letters
after my name
that's why i get paid more way more in
fact than many of these like qualified
you know apa certified you know board
certified psychotherapists that are
utterly useless you know for the most
part you know with the exception of a
very small handful
but the point that i'm making though is
is
don't worry about other people's
problems
don't let their problems become your
problems unplugged alphas don't let
other people's problems become their
problems they just walk away from it
i'll tell you you know the other day i
had a guy
on a phone call and he was a vendor and
he was behind on something and he's
giving me all these reasons why he's
behind on the project and i just said to
my god look don't make your problems my
problems this is what i expected this
was the deadline date figure it out
right if you're not qualified to do it
then i'll find somebody else that can do
it i don't want to spend time there
figuring out what his problems are so
that he can take care of my problems
that i'm paying him to fix
right that's that's one of the areas
that you're going wrong with turtle is
is you're spending way too much time
thinking
well you know if we just raise the tide
all the ships will come up
that's not your responsibility you have
a responsibility to yourself and nobody
else fix that first
well rich i really appreciate you
everybody i'm here for you back in your
challenge and it's always a pleasure
thank you for
thank you for all right man
you got it take care peace
you